he can be sometimes a little obnoxious i
think but he's very funny
uh not funny in the way that you like
want to laugh all the time but you're
kind of like ah
offends me so he's a jerk no he's not a
jerk i like him he's just i wouldn't
necessarily like curl up with him and
watch breaking bad don't say anything my
brain but i haven't seen season five yet
you are so weird
it ruins the whole thing i stopped
talking about it you're done you're done
we're not talking about it okay
who's that guy he's some cheesy old
loser who's in this round like
the 90s the 90s kill me perfect circle
around me
dancing you always want to dance with me
i am mindy obstetrics in gynecology
tom roll surgery
[Music]
oh god okay that she's your loser is the
guy almost married tom
tom
[Music]
all right i'm gonna open it up and open
up here
you're right tom no okay my bad man that
was your bad oh god tom
tom tom tom are you okay
hey hey hey how are you i'm okay are you
all right
legs are great yeah you're doing really
well cool i bought a ring oh is it
bleeding
oh yeah it bleeds a lot yeah i have like
no pillowcases at my house yes so what
have you been up to
i moved yeah westchester wasn't really
doing it for me anymore so yeah now i
live in a furnished apartment
yeah back in the city uh right across
the street from the holocaust museum
oh no we're in by the entrance it's by
the entrance so it's people are very
happy going in
from the ladies oh wow hey that's very
much god
thanks for the drinks thank you very
much ladies this is what we think your
drinks
you don't pick us we pick you whoa
bounce
they seem nice enough oh no no they seem
nice enough next thing you know
we go home with these girls then you're
married
and then you find a condom in your dog
poop and you go
whoa someone having sex with my dog then
you realize no
your wife is having sex with someone and
the dog ate the condom all right
we'll just hang with the guys all right
danny yeah quick quick quick quick work
yeah sure
tommy's unhinged no i know yeah he's
insane
okay yes i admit that was a very
chilling story
but he's gone to her a lot i mean look
at him go
out hey foul man chris humphries no
dunking wnba rules
give me the gun what gun what are you
talking about this is clearly a suicide
ring
oh it's nice suicide yeah what a
suicidal loser drain a shot like this
trey oh
my bad game over guys i'm sorry all
right let's break it down
all right let's look here oh the gums
are looking nice
yeah you never know they came from a
cadaver
that's good very nice caroline
and what are you doing here
tom mindy i need to speak to you about
an urgent matter look manny we're not
dating anymore so i can't give you free
toothbrushes
i already got my free toothbrushes so
joke's on you come on just
hold on come on come on uh how is your
wife doing
she's good she's good yeah she's gone
she moved back to serbia
but that's cool whatevs you know i mean
now i get to do what i want to do
which is hang out with my friends all
right talk to my lawyer
sell the boat that me and my dad made
last time i saw you you were expecting a
baby
yeah it turns out the baby looked a lot
like her ex-boyfriend boris lovko
hey that's awful no no it's a good thing
you know that means they were sleeping
with each other
while we were married i get the
implications i didn't even masturbate
when we were married
yeah hey tom how's it going
good hey you look great whoa hey
is that an engagement ring yeah it is i
did it
i got engaged that's i'm so happy for
you thank you
so happy for you okay i feel i feel your
penis against my thighs oh okay who's
lucky guy
his name is casey actually you know him
yeah he kicked my ass i remember that
for the record yes
tom did ask me to go home with him and
if this has been a year ago i would have
done it
it would have totally rocked your world
really cause i learned a lot of cool new
stuff
from this guy from some other guys too
great what but i'm not gonna do that
because i'm a grown-up totally
understand totally understand that this
guy was trying to have sex with my
girlfriend
i'm good i'm good oh god tom i'm drunk
i'm sorry i just i'm
mindy i'm a man of god and i i'm not
acting like it dude all right no i get
drunk people get drunk sometimes
okay punch your teeth down your throat
i'm an orthodontic i got buckets of
teeth i'm a minister you're trying to
kill a minister
are we just yelling our jobs now maybe
we are
all right
just calm down put him down at the
foosball
come on
i need you to come back to work no no
that's a hostile place right here
with these guys this is a safe
environment yeah yeah and you are
covered in sweat
you got you that your body's trying to
tell you something sorry why is our sex
tape on the internet
i i had nothing to do with that i swear
on my mother's grave
i had nothing to do with that no wait i
i had something to do with that oh my
gosh i lent it to my brother when he got
divorced
what if it makes any difference it
really helped he had a bad case of the
blues
i am very sorry this is peter my
colleague this is tom tom peter
super disappointed you man yes i am also
pretty silly to meet you you're my new
favorite male porn star
shut up look i just started dating my
dental assistant okay
i don't need this we're coming up on our
two-month anniversary so stop with the
point
hey we're out of gauze should i order
gauze
yeah angel do whatever you want okay
how am i supposed to get anything done
with that in my face all day
okay pretty awesome loser all right
that's just what we do man he's just
having a good time see just playing
around we shove
heads okay i'm sorry i'm sorry these
guys love me is tom's friend anyone here
i have no friends we should leave here
last time i was here someone shot me
oh i see while the cat's away the mouse
will troll for
wean in a dive bar you're on weenus
patrol
lieutenant i'm not on women's patrol
food
get out of the car please get out of the
pants please
i'm gonna i'm gonna go hang out with us
you've been will you hang out with me
what okay i'm so happy for you i'm gonna
they're calling me over a second
he's calling you no one's calling
co-workers bye no bye danny
bye-bye i'm doing okay i'm doing okay i
really am
you know i i was a little depressed
there for a little bit i'd wake up in
the morning have my coffee
you know exercise do a little russian
roulette breakups
are the worst they are the worst i
actually
broke up with my boyfriend today i'm
sorry i guess that explains why we're
both at a frat party
with a guy named the gooch
oh that's erin
oh my god oh god i can't unsee this
i've never done this before hey that's
burned in my retina
ah oh tommy own me get away from her
with that thing
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no you give this to me you
sicko danny
i give it to tom like 10 years ago it
means nothing oh you were you taking it
slow when you made this with tom where's
this medium speed for you
no that's faster than medium scale hey
do not look at that it was the 2000s
okay you were kind of a loser if you
didn't have a sex tape
hey danny move it oh god kill me
i know you think that mindy embarrassed
the practice before you get all judgy
reinhold on her
listen to what tom has to say okay
margo's out in the hallway
so let's not talk about the sex tape now
she thinks i'm a virgin
okay you know what what are you doing
i'm gonna pull the plug stop it
right there tom tell him about the time
that you spent together with me
why does he need to know that why is
that a deal margo would you like to come
in here and watch a movie that's not
nice you're not being nice enough hey
back
back honey not nice that's not nice you
just slam the door
danny listen uh i don't think mindy ever
really liked me that much
okay you know i think we did all the
freaky sex stuff because
we didn't like spending time with each
other and when i say freaky i mean like
really freaky
did you ever tape anything most of it
what where's this going i'm just saying
i think she would have dumped me after
two weeks if i didn't have such a huge
costume
okay all right that's enough every time
i see you you bring that up mindy
why'd you date this dude because i got a
huge penis
really oh come on i can feel your penis
if it's black
you